[Musique]
alors est ce que vous vous souvenez de
vos premières expériences en course à
pied
pas simple quand on était enfant conques
secours après non notre première
expérience en course à pied sel quand on
était au collège au lycée quand on est
en rond autour d'un stade
celle où quelques années plus tard on se
décide de remettre les baskets pour se
donner bonne conscience ou démarré un
régime
voilà c'est de ces expériences là que je
voudrais qu'on parle
personnellement je détestais la course à
pied et je pense que dans l'ensemble on
est tous d'accord au départ la course à
pied c'est juste horrible et je vous
parle pas du vélo parce que je me pose
encore la question entre les deux le
qualité le pire pour moi et j'ai mal aux
fesses j'ai mal aux jambes
et dès que ça monte j'ai envie de
pousser le vélo vous avez peut-être pas
me croire mais ces deux activités que je
détestais je me suis mis à les adorer
est un passionné pour elle alors comment
est ce que s'est passé en fait à l'âge
de 16 ans je trouve un petit job d'été
et n'ayant pas de scooter dans mon
garage je me retrouve obligé de prendre
mon vélo pour le boulot ailleurs
moi qui avais 7 km d'autonomie nous
voilà obligés de prendre mon vélo chaque
jour pour aller au boulot finalement ça
s'est plutôt bien passé ça m'a permis de
dépasser mes limites
inconsciemment grâce à cette motivation
d'aller au travail je me suis retrouvé à
faire plus de 20 km 20 km tout seul
exceptionnel exceptionnel pour moi et
finalement j'ai commencé à me passionner
pour ce sport mais je me suis pas arrêté
là j'ai continué je continue à pédaler
accumuler des kilomètres jusqu'au jour
où je passe le cap des 100 km 100 km à
pédaler tout seul sans m'arrêter
c'était juste exceptionnel pour moi je
m'en rappellerai toute ma vie de ce jour
là et là je m'arrête pas là je continue
je continue 120 150 200 km jusqu'au jour
où je me lance un défi partir de
saint-etienne dans la loire et rejoindre
la côte d'azur 450 km en deux jours 450
km qui me semblait impossible au départ
et finalement je réussi ce défi et je
commence à prendre conscience
la force du mental sur le physique alors
maintenant revenons à mon pire ennemi
la course à pied alors quelques années
avant de réaliser ce défi je me dis
tiens et si je complimente est un peu
mes entraînements par un peu de course à
pied voilà partis pour un tour de 8 km 8
petits kilomètres qui ont été
certainement les pierres qui lui
kilomètres de toute ma vie je suis
rentré j'étais complètement exténué
épuisé j'ai pris mes chaussures je les
ai jetés à travers la maison et je dis
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce sport
mais qu'est ce que c'est de ce que ce
sport comment les gens peuvent-ils
prendre plaisir à courir
c'est ensuite quelques années de sevrage
et je me retourne un moment donné je le
faire du raid aventure alors l aventure
c'est un enchaînement à d'activités
outdoor avec du vtt du kayak et
notamment de la course d'orientation
alors le problème c'est que dans course
d'orientation ya course
alors là me voilà obligé de partir
courir m'a finalement avec une approche
assez ludique courir dans la forêt à la
recherche de balises mais ma limite des
8 km elle a disparu
je me retrouve à courir pendant 1h30 2h
2h30 sans m'en rendre compte et à
découvrir une nouvelle passion la course
à pied en nature plus communément appelé
le trail running
alors pour ceux qui sont d'annecy ou de
la région de chamonix
vous devez certainement connaître le
trail running parce que chaque année fin
août se déroule le plus gros événement
de trail l'eni moment l'utmb l'ultra
trail du mont blanc
alors le concept est relativement simple
vous partez de chamonix en courant ou
fait le tour du mont blanc en passant
par l'italie et la suisse
et vous ramener à chamonix assez simple
à on est d'accord sauf qu'en pratique
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
vous avez 170 km à parcourir non stop
170 km et accrochez vous vous avez dit
1000 mètres de dénivelé
alors vous donner une petite image 10000
mètres de dénivelé ça représente plus de
deux fois l'ascension du mont blanc et
sa redescente plus de deux fois
l'ascension du mont blanc
alors pour vous donner quelques chiffres
complémentaires alors c'est une épreuve
qui dure entre 20 heures et quarante six
heures non-stop ou le répète on dépense
l'équivalent d'environ quinze mille
calories en bois à peu près entre 15 et
20 litres d'eau suivant les conditions
ce qui représente deux packs d'eau et
tout ça ça représente une semaine d'une
vie classique en terme de dépense
énergétique qu'on compresse sur le temps
d'effort je vous laisse imaginer
l'exigence de ce type d'épreuve
et là vous devez vous dire c'est juste
impossible c'est exactement ce que je
pensais en 2008 quand j'ai découvert
cette épreuve jusqu'au moment où je vois
des hommes et des femmes passé la ligne
d'arrivée et obtenir le statut de
finisher à partir de là je me dis mais
comment des gens sont ils capables de
pousser leurs corps a terminé ce type
d'épreuve comment font-ils pour gérer
leur mental pour arriver à faire le tour
du mont blanc
et là je me dis mais s'il y arrive est
ce que moi j'ai les capacités de le
faire aussi est ce que je serais capable
un jour de terminer annuités mb alors à
partir de là je décide de m'investir
dans la pratique
alors pendant plusieurs années
j'augmente progressivement ma distance
j'augmente protection des nids vais je
veux aussi la durée j'accumule d
expérience au travers de mes réussites
mais aussi de mes échecs
tout ça ça me permet d'apprendre
j'apprends ce que c'est que réellement
avoir soif réellement avoir faim
réellement avoir froid l'énorme plaisir
une bonne pizza
lemay
le plaisir de prendre une douche bien
chaude mais sam apprend aussi surtout à
gérer mon corps avec les hauts et les
bas qu'au front l'ultra trail avec ce
moment d'euphorie et ses moments de
déprime et cela prend surtout à gérer
mon mental alors partir de là vous devez
vous demander mais qu'est ce qui se
passe dans leur tête pendant un an qui
courent compresse qu'ils font pour
arriver à akure aussi longtemps alors ça
va être un peu compliqué mais essayez de
vous imaginer
il est deux heures du matin vous avez
pris le départ de la course la veille à
8 heures et ça fait dix-huit heures vous
courrez couru toute la journée une
partie de la nuit votre corps est
complètement exténué il vous demande
qu'une chose c'est s'arrêter pour se
reposer sauf qu'ils vous restent 60 km à
parcourir à partir de là vous allez
vraiment rentré dans la dimension du
mental
votre corps était capable de vous amener
jusqu'à une certaine distance maintenant
c'est notre mental qui va vous amener
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée
à partir de là vous n'avez plus le droit
de vous écouter fini les émotions fini
les sensations vous avez un objectif à
rejoindre cette ligne d'arrivée et là
vous devez avancer
vous devez avancer avancer avancer
jusqu'à cette ligne pour enfin ressentir
cette satisfaction du défi accompli et à
ce moment là vous vous remémorez ce
moment il ya 60 km vous étiez à deux
doigts d'abandonner vous vous sentiez
incapable de la rejoindre
et finalement vous êtes contredit vous
êtes capables alors là où je me
retrouvais ya quelques années à
m'écoeurer à tourner en rond autour d'un
stade
aujourd'hui je me retrouve à m'épanouir
et à me découvrir moi même à tourner en
rond autour du mont-blanc torse
je suis pas du tout en train de vous
faire la promotion de l'ultra trail loin
de là je sais que c'est une activité
extrême et pour être honnête je pense
pas qu'elle aime beaucoup d'entre vous
qui soient tentés par l'aventuré
ce qui est important pour moi c'est de
nous faire prendre conscience du
paradoxe du mental
ce mental qui me créer mais barrière
limite mes contradictions et au final
c'est ce mental là qui m'a permis de les
dépasser
alors certes le sport était pour moi un
moyen de me découvrir ou de découvrir la
force du mental
mais tout ceci c'est transférables aussi
à plein de domaines dans notre vie du
quotidien
imaginez une personne qui décide
d'arrêter de fumer personne qui décide
de faire un régime ou tout simplement ma
présence aujourd'hui sur scène à vous
raconte à une part de ma vie nouveau
certificat quelques années j'aurais été
incapable de le faire alors je vous
invite
je vous invite à les découvrir les
limites qui vous entoure ses limites qui
sont autour de boutiques parfois vous
servent de barrières allez les découvrir
et que vous allez voir qu'elle ne sont
pas là pas forcément là où pensiez les
trouver alors un petit conseil c'est de
respecter un principe le principe de
progressivité
prenez le temps d'aller découvrir votre
votre environnement
prenez le temps d'avancé ne cherchez pas
aller trop loin d'un coup sinon le
chemin risque d'être trop long et vous
risquez de vous en écoeuré prenez aussi
le temps de vous retourner pour voir le
chemin que vous avez parcouru par les
empreintes de vos anciennes limites et
surtout admirer les défis que vous avez
réalisé alors pour conclure je voudrais
reprendre une maxime qui me tient à
coeur qui à mon sens c'est autant
transférables dans le sport que dans la
vie il ya une ligne de départ et ligne
d'arrivée et entre les deux il ya une
aventure unique à vivre
alors allez-y motivé vous partez à la
découverte de vous même merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]